All right, let's continue.
We have so much to discuss and so much to
cover.
There is a very, very notable breaking news
that there are cabinet members actually discussing,
invoking the 25th Amendment to remove Donald
Trump from office.
Now, the fact that they're considering it
is the story.
I don't believe it will happen.
I think ultimately it's going to be a lot
of well, if I supported it, would you supported
it if the two of us did?
What about you?
Will would Pence go for it?
But the 25th Amendment, I don't believe, ultimately
will be invoked, but it is being discussed.
CNN reporting that there are cabinet members
holding preliminary discussions about invoking
the 25th Amendment to force Donald Trump to
leave office early.
And it is unclear whether there will be enough
cabinet members in favor to result in Donald
Trump's removal.
But this has now been widely reported by CNN,
The Hill and numerous other outlets.
It is abundantly clear that the conversation
is happening in light of the violent riots
that were fomented yesterday by Donald Trump.
House Judiciary Democrats have also written
a letter to Mike Pence asking him to invoke
the 25th Amendment, although I don't believe
there's it.
If it happens or if it's being seriously considered,
it's not because Democrats are asking for
it.
But Congressman David Cicilline did write
a letter in which he says, Dear Vice President
Pence, it is with great sadness that we write
to you following the incidents that unfolded
where he goes on to, say, Section four of
the 25th Amendment to the Constitution provides
the vice president and majority of sitting
cabinet secretaries with the authority to
determine a president as unfit if they are
unable to discharge the powers and duties
of the office.
Going on to say for the sake of democracy,
we emphatically urge you to invoke the 25th
Amendment and begin the process of removing
President Trump from power.
Obviously, Donald Trump should be removed
from power.
Obviously, Donald Trump should have already
been impeached.
The Georgia phone call was an impeachable
offense.
There have been other impeachable offenses.
We could go back to talk about Saudi Arabia
and Yemen.
I mean, it's we're going back quite a way
when we are now just 13 days from the end,
one way or another.
I don't believe that this will happen.
And I think it's also important to say one
one other thing about this.
We'll be talking a little bit later about
Republicans now who are bailing on Donald
Trump there.
They're done in 13 days.
The idea that now they are being brave and
defiant and moral and upstanding guys.
There's 13 days left.
If you want to point to anyone.
I mean, listen, John McCain from the beginning
was I'm not a big McCain guy.
But from the beginning, McCain said what he
believed.
He didn't wait until there was no political
risk.
Mitt Romney, his opposition to Trump is quite
milquetoast, but it's been consistent after
he had that weird frog leg lunch with with
Trump, where it seemed like maybe he could
be Trump's secretary of state.
But it's been years that at least Mitt Romney
has been consistent.
And it's not like a big deal.
He's mildly critical of Donald Trump in most
cases with a few more serious critiques.
But he was exposed to the downsides of doing
it for years.
These people now who in the middle of the
night last night when everybody had already
mostly tuned out, came and said, you know,
listen, our role here is just to count.
And that's what we have to do.
There's nothing else we can do or some of
the resignations that are taking place now,
including like from Mick Mulvaney, who who
even remembered that Mulvaney was still even
working for the Trump White House.
This is it's too little, too late.
And we can't now put them back on the good
boys list as a result of them doing this.
That's very important to keep in mind.
Again, the big story is the mere fact that
the use of the 25th Amendment is being considered
is absolutely insane.
It should be used.
There are mental health professionals like
Dr. Bandele, who we've interviewed who are
now asking for a 72 hour psych hold for Donald
Trump.
Most of this stuff is merely symbolic, but
the fact that it's taking place really confirms
the dystopian reality in which we are living.
And then also importantly, and we'll talk
about this next, Donald Trump has agreed to
leave office.
And I know it sounds like wait, how is that
news?
But given the circumstances, it is